I always knew it was difficult to make
friends and you know and of course you
define the meaning of friends I am I had
to struggle a lot in under school in the
schools that before college I had a lot
of stuff I had to deal with externally
fights and stuff like that to protect
myself and then when I got older I had
so many things to do I was an actor at
an early age and I was always dashing
off to be a member of the football team
or be an actor or whatever I was doing I
was busy so that making friends was a
skill I I didn't realize I didn't know
you make friends like have you ever
wondered what an opera singer goes
through to have that divine voice it's a
skill that's learned you exercise that
muscle the way a muscle body builder
builds their biceps you can learn to
sing maybe not as great as as one of
those gifted Naturals but you can if you
spent ten years learn to sing you can
learn to do anything and if you're
taught at an early enough age character
manifestations like making friends the
ability to make a friend here's what you
do I mean you've got to be nice you got
to do this you it takes time you've got
to have commonality you've got to have
mutual interest you've got to if that
laughter you have to be
you can't be sarcastic you can't be mean
you can't all those things that need
that a child needs to learn I may not
have had that in a large degree I don't
know but I think it was because I was
very busy I made a friend with Leonard
that I thought often asked people who
were I'm talking to or being interviewed
by do you have a friend do you have a
friend and you know there that the
puzzle about it and I think that's what
marriage is you make a friend and now
it's memorialized in writing and but
there's an element of passion there that
that I think takes it takes it somewhere
else than the friendship I'm talking
about that's a very difficult thing to
do to have that the brotherly love that
I'm talking about and but it's possible
and that's what Leonard might have
taught me
you